i mean all of these games i have 100
yeah yeah um
in terms of like uh pokemon silver the
original silver
it's the one game where i've actually
broken the in-game timer
like i played so much of silver right
now yeah
how did you do that what is the in-game
timer the in-game time the max in-game
timer is 999
hours and that's reasonable which is
reasonable it's like a thousand hours
right but the only way i achieve that is
because of
like you know obviously you play through
the game and then you're like okay
well i've finished i've gotten all 16
badges what do i do now yeah
complete the decks okay i'll do that
what's the step after that
get every pokemon to level 100. okay
i've done that
right get all the shinies
i did that to myself because at the time
right
i was borrowing my friend's game boy
color right like we kind of like this
was during the time where like i had
like a couple of childhood friends like
lived nearby where we met each other
often enough where it's like
can i borrow your n64 or can i borrow
your super nintendo or whatever
yeah so i never actually owned the game
boy collar
and but i had pokemon silver
um i don't remember where i got it from
maybe i borrowed it from a friend
again i got it probably like that
probably something like that but like
i borrowed the gameboy color enough
times where i was like
and it was the only gameboy yeah and
also
silver was the only gameboy color game i
had right as well so it's like
whenever i saw the game boy college just
sitting on my desk i'm like well i mean
i could just [ __ ]
play this yeah i'm gonna kill some time
and as a kid you know you have no
concept of time as you're playing a game
right so it's like
so yeah i just [ __ ] was like well
literally got nothing else to do other
than i guess i'll just try and catch all
the shinies
oh my god and i [ __ ] did that and
that sounds like torture
and i maxed out the in-game clock i was
like oh 999 is the max all right i got
it now jesus yeah
i'm telling you like you think you're
like you know god thinks he's like
you know once you're into a game you get
addicted to it yeah i get [ __ ]
no no no no no no i i know you do you're
on another level
and like kirby's uh nightmare in
dreamland was the first ever game i
owned because the game advance was the
first console i own i think i've played
that game
i've never played a single kirby game
okay this game was the game that got me
to kirby
right since then i [ __ ] love every
kirby game and like i'm telling you like
if you're ever feeling sad just play a
kirby you
it might be the most like you're
childish yeah so i'm gonna prescribe you
a copy of
cubby's dream literally if like you
might think it's like
childish and dumb and like [ __ ] easy
or whatever yeah but
it is literally impossible to play a
kirby game
and not be happy like it's it's just
it's
the challenge except there is there is
something
there's something about it where it's
like i might be in the shittiest [ __ ]
mood
and i'll play like 30 minutes of any
kirby game yeah immediately happy
right and like i think that's why i
liked playing it because i was like i
don't want to play a game that makes me
sad i mean later on in my adulthood
i was like heavy rain
yes metal gear solid give me all of that
sure yes uh i i would like a bit of
depression please
and uh and i think again like that's
another reason why i like played a lot
of like animal crossing for example or
like
you know again like pokemon it's like
you can't you put animal crossing in
like
the top nine in your life yeah damn yeah
yeah okay
because every like this one in
particular well well
yeah honestly wild world specifically
because
i was [ __ ] obsessed with the ds and
this was one of the few
this is the ds one i was gonna say cause
i heard a lot of like you know uh now
that ever
now that people have like calmed down
about an animal crossing the first one
i've heard a lot of people being like
you know
it is good but it does feel like it's
lacking in a lot of ways yeah and that
they're adding in the functions that
were in the previous ones yeah yeah yeah
literally
all the add-ons that they currently
added
yeah so this is gonna sound so like
boomer or not not boomer but like what
is the point of animal crossing yeah i
mean i i
i feel like i'm trying to understand why
there's like anti-vaxxers when i'm
watching
like i like i hear i hear what you're
saying i get it but i'm seeing it and
i'm like i don't get it at all
i i totally get people which is why i
was really shocked at
how popular the newest one got yeah
because to me
animal crossing a lot like harvest moon
yeah i always thought was like that
one niche series where it's like if you
weren't into it from the beginning
doesn't matter how many new games they
bring out you'll never get into it i
mean like the more people talk about it
the more i'm just like well this is just
a pay your mortgage simulator yeah so
i i watch it and i'm like okay so you go
hit that rock and then you get some
stone okay and then you go and talk to a
guy who gives you a
recipe for something that you didn't
want and then you go and make that thing
and it's like a cabinet that you might
not need and then i'm like
and then i'm confused if you don't want
it you can sell that and then everything
is just seems
so slow and of course it's nintendo so
[ __ ] is just unnecessarily complicated
like i saw someone going to like uh
someone else's island
and it took like a minute of like cut
scenes to go to someone's island or
something yeah and then like everything
just seemed
slow in it and i was like why i think
that's the
entire point of animal crossing it's
supposed to be slow because
it's not supposed to be like i feel like
i hate games that make me wait like
artificial waiting it's the slice of
life of video games
[Music]
animal crossing sims uh [ __ ]
uh harvest moon see i i get all [ __ ]
like
i get the sims though right because
you're kind of like you're kind of
trying to you
you're kind of like living a life like
that maybe that maybe you couldn't like
live
in real life you know what's really
weird i never got into the sims
i know i never got into the sims i
always thought sims was really boring
yeah which is weird because of an animal
crossing because the thing is i really
like
simulation games but i've never like
never a life simulator game
i've always liked what it is you know
why i never go into the seams because it
wasn't cute
honestly i i understand that honestly
you look at harvest moon you look at
animal crossing you're like that's
[ __ ] adorable
i was i was never into sims but like
when i started voice acting and it's a
weird tangent yeah
like i started seeing sims voice acting
projects
everywhere right people making their own
movies in sims
this was a huge thing oh yeah like
machinima yeah and i was just like
what the [ __ ] this is ugly and it looks
dumb yeah and it's like the animations
of sims like
yeah and then they would have to like
voice act to it and i'm not i'm not
auditioning for that [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
i don't know
i feel like that's part of the like old
age of the incident
there's some campiness to it that i feel
like has its own charm yeah right
absolutely they would be like it's like
this oscar-worthy drama performed via
sims animation
it's like what the [ __ ] but i think
that's the whole appeal right because
when
uh animal crossing first came out right
i think i read this somewhere
and correct me if i'm wrong internet but
i think the whole appeal of animal
crossing was it was supposed to be
marketed towards
housewives in japan right who wanted
something to do as you know their
husbands or significant others were out
working all day yeah that's literally
how they marketed it because i was like
it was a non-challenging game
no literally it was like it was a game
where it was like are you tired of being
in the kitchen all day yeah literally
it's like because it's it's so not
challenging and also it's non-stressful
either
it's like it's a game that like
literally just gets all your stress off
because you forget about everything in
the
in the your real world yeah where you
can just focus on a completely
separate just there are no you know
stresses or no
i guess like bad things to happen with
like any consequence whatsoever in this
world right so
it's literally nintendo was like i'mma
create a distraction
for stressed adults and call it animal
crossing because i remember my first
and only experience with animal crossing
was the original animal crossing on the
gamecube
right and the only reason i knew about
it right
was because i don't i think for the
longest time it just wasn't available in
the uk like
it was only available like they
translated but it was only available in
the us
yeah and i had heard about it from like
this nintendo gaming pc
i don't know nothing gaming magazine
yeah gaming magazine gaming magazine
that's what i meant to say this nintendo
gaming magazine
and they were like it just got like
super good reviews and i'm just like
holy [ __ ] this must be a banger of the
game every [ __ ] review is given
every review is giving this five out of
five i'm just like holy [ __ ] this this
this this is a must-get game why is this
not available in the uk right so i
literally had to like
look up some like import websites and
like
like seriously like i had to import
animal crossing from the us
yeah buy like a specialized import disk
where like because
um yeah because um old gamecube games
were region logs so you couldn't just
put a us disk into a uk device
you needed a special disk that you
needed to insert into the gamecube
um to region unlock it so that you could
put animal crossing
yeah yeah and so i had to research and
do that to do that by myself with a
very limited budget because i i didn't
really have much of a budget to work
with back then
um but i i had saved up and i brought
animal crossing
and i was just like this is going to be
amazing guys this is going to be an
amazing game
i've imported this game which is [ __ ]
expensive to import a game and i bought
like
extra hardware on top of that just so i
could play the game yeah because every
review said it was amazing yeah
and then i started playing it i'm just
like when's the gameplay kicking
i was like okay it's an awfully long
cutscene yeah yeah i was like okay
okay i was i was picking apples i'm just
like so i'm
the gameplay is going to kick in
sometime i'm going to have a point to
why i'm doing this because i i expected
it to be on the same level as like
pokemon or stuff like that when i'm
catching stuff or i'm like
i'm going on an adventure yeah and i'm
just like okay
surely when i play pay off this mortgage
that's when the gameplay will kick in
so i play i play animal crossing and
like and i
and i [ __ ] paid tom nook back or
whatever the [ __ ] is i pay off
i pay off my mortgage because i'm just
like there must be a reason why
every game every magazine is giving this
five stars
pay off my mortgage and then the game
just continues
and then tom looks like here's another
mortgage